researchers create a smart toilet that
can identify unique
prints and monitor your
health I've been saying this like I
wanted to go on Shark Tank with a with a
with a
camera this is what the the the smart
toilet should be telling you this keep
wiping
right two more wipes buddy oo
looking destroyed today everything okay
I mean that's where the AI should go I
have a toothbrush that lets you know
that you're brushing your teeth too hard
and then you ease up it has like lights
on it and then there's an app is there's
an app that like it'll show you where
you've brushed your teeth in your mouth
and you can like go around and be like
oh I didn't get this side I yeah I want
the toilet to do that you know let you
know you know you need to know that that
butthole is
pristine